vt haze video word on the street is you
and amber looking for a house yeah you
got one yeah let's go like the wind gun
yeah let's go rain why you come on no
forget it what's up guys my name is
curly and today we're helping my friend
see teen amber find their new home using
realtor calm how did y'all meet I found
out that amber and I both were childhood
speakers haters the first time we were
in the ring and I remember like her
looking up at me putting on her skates I
was like oh no I'm in love with this
girl
Wow now you guys are like living
together how long have you guys been
living together for I like that now you
guys are like ready for later and
upgrade yeah 100% of the time there's a
soundtrack it's amber singing but we
live an apartment we share walls please
no how did she ceiling why does the
feeling have to be like that I think
there's a reason no there's no reason
the reason is like the 70s yeah let's
look at how much house can we afford
look you know like level up in their
love life and in their adult life so
home is really like the next big step
but our property types inside stories I
thought they're really the house has a
story it's fantastic yeah there's a lot
of talk about kids there's a lot of talk
about possibly having like a music
studio what are you looking for it's
definitely like an outdoor space Jeremy
the cat needs a beautiful window he's a
bit of a prince also a bathtub so today
I feel like we could potentially find a
new dream home I'm just gonna go ahead
and send you some links using the app
right now you can actually save them
into your profile we could find the
house that they build their new life in
we could find the home that they have a
little baby in I'm super stoked because
I'm like the ultimate G samosa and I
just want to see what these houses look
like oh my gosh it's huge beautiful
we're gonna check it out yes
I would have been working to me to write
I think it is real look at that
oh it just goes on and on loving the
wrap-around island I always go for
sitting on the island now this is luxury
somewhere in my life I'm just doing
ballet right Oh closet space hello this
two showerheads Wow her own control is
sexy there's a lot of backyard there's
so much potential out here no listen to
me
oh wait wait you guys we have a
notification from realtor calm the Blue
Door house just went down in price so
we're on our way to the second house
what did you guys think about the first
time I love the first I loved it I adore
it yeah I'm excited to see what this
other house is gonna look like okay this
is like a real porch if we get a porch
swing yeah I'll hang a porch swing whoa
oh my gosh the like kitchen as a whole
yeah is a lot bigger seeing an omelet
bar slepping them out right this is the
same sure this is for your shows you got
show us up here I remember seeing
streaming like that's beautiful room the
pictures on the app will look like the
house yeah
[Music]
gonna love it he's so spoiled the nice
size that is real good guestroom this is
an office space
[Music]
not enough window so hate it no hate
this room this is wonderful it's like a
little hideaway this is the greatest
backyard of all time hills are alive and
the very first thing that we're doing is
setting up an outdoor movie heater
that's a projector okay guys so we saw
two houses what did you guys think
starting with the first house we saw it
is beautiful they had bigger windows
that shower though double-headed shower
that was huge the kitchen is small could
you smell that
I feel like it was definitely doable
what were some of the pros and cons of
this house it's beautiful entertaining
house tons of space the kitchen is
bigger but I'm not sure that this house
feels right for a family yeah so if you
guys have to pick between the two I'm
going with the other one I want to pay
this price for the other one I can't
believe this hmm I love it okay you're
into it I think I have so the next step
would be to find a real tear okay let's
find a realtor do it do this yeah I also
claimed her room already
yes really zero the big one the master
[Music]